Auto parts supplier Takata has declared bankruptcy,
but that was not a huge surprise after it
caused the biggest recall in US auto history.
Roughly 120 million of Takata’s airbags
have been deemed potentially unsafe worldwide.
More than half of those are in the United
States.
In fact, the U.S. recall is bigger than the
next five largest U.S. recalls combined and
affects roughly one in every five cars in
the United States.
So if you own a car made in the last 15 years,
there’s a good chance your car has a bad
airbag.
Takata supplied airbags to major manufacturers
like Honda.
And Toyota, And Ford.
And all these guys.
Takata and automakers haven’t decided how
to split the cost of years of recalls.
So what went wrong?
It isn’t just that the bags aren’t inflating.
When a car with one of these faulty bags gets
into an accident, the airbag can explode.
They use a chemical called Ammonium Nitrate
as a propellant, but over time it begins to
destabilize.
The casing that’s holding the ammonium nitrate
breaks apart, and it does so so violently
that it ends up sending metal shards flying
into drivers and passengers.
Eleven people in the US alone have died from
Takata airbag shrapnel - almost all of them
in the southern part of the country.
It turns out long exposure to heat and humidity
are what’s causing the Ammonium Nitrate
to destabilize..
Takata admitted to hiding the danger posed
by its exploding airbags in a plea deal with
U.S. prosecutors in February in which it agreed
to pay regulators, consumers, and carmakers
$1 billion in penalties.
You can go to this website (safercar.gov)
to see if your car is on the list using the
car’s 17-digit VIN number, but if it is,
be prepared to wait.
It could be a while before you can get your
car fixed.
Since airbags on each make and model of car
are unique, replacing 64 million of them requires
a lot of parts that are in very high demand.
Completing all of the recalls may take well
into 2020.
The huge cost of of the airbag crisis finally
brought Takata down.
In June 2017, The company filed for Chapter-11
bankruptcy listing more than $10 billion in
liabilities.
Most of Takata’s assets will be acquired
for around $1.6 billion by a Chinese-owned
company, Key Safety Systems.
The money from that sale is expected to help cover ongoing costs related to the airbag recalls
Meanwhile, as drivers wait for their airbags
to be fixed -- they’re left with cars that
are potentially dangerous to drive, all because
of a device that was put there to keep them
safe.